and this is this is what happens they
shove the lgbtq plus [__] down your
throat you know most people don't really
care what you do in your house it used
to be you know what you do in your
bedroom is your business we don't care
but keep us out of it but it's when they
start shoving this stuff down our
throats when they demand that we must
have Flags dedicated to it where they
over represent the amount of lgbtq and
whatever Plus the trans people on TV
shows when we're now having kids shows
with gay people in it where we're now
having
um propaganda in school where they're
pushing gay sex onto children and
explaining what that is to kids that
have nothing to do with this stuff when
that starts happening that's where the
ride has a problem